[Music]
or let the pros do it maybe let the pros
do it
our extreme summer heat can affect how
often you fill up your gas tank the
energy department says if you run your
air conditioner as we do in southern
nevada that cuts fuel economy by more
than 25 percent that's because your car
is working extra hard to cool down that
puts more stress on the engine but there
are some ways to make the heat easier on
your car
roll those windows down you can go ahead
and slowly bump that ac up let it get
cool let the car warm up just a touch
before you really kick it into high gear
of course idling is a gas guzzler as
well you really shouldn't idle if you
can avoid it it's even worse in the heat
so try and avoid routes with heavy
traffic because then you're idling all
the time
park in the shade use a sunscreen we do
that a lot here that'll kind of keep
your car from baking
and of course use your car's
recirculation button for air
conditioning there's a little circle
button on the devices the under on the
console
that'll help your car save energy
while you're driving
alright news